[Music]
animation isn't always meant for
children sometimes it can get pretty
dark scandalous and violent but which of
these works are among the most important
to keep from impressionable eyes well
we're here to tell you about the
cartoons you should never watch in front
of your kids
hey let's see if you remember this movie
it's roughly 30 years old and takes
place in a world inhabited by
live-action humans and animated cartoon
characters
much of it takes place in a stylized
somewhat seedy vision of america in the
1940s a world full of private detectives
small-time hustlers and gorgeous dames
concealing complex agendas tension
seethes between the humans and the
cartoons and a reckoning is imminent
luckily an unlikely partnership between
two people from both sides emerges and
the day is saved for human and cartoon
alike it's gotta be who framed roger
rabbit right
wrong we're talking about cool world
which despite its many similarities to
the 1988 disney classic is distinguished
by one massive difference it is very
much not for kids though it too tells
the story of a down on his luck dude
inhabiting an animated landscape the
titular cool world tempts him with all
manner of r-rated debauchery most
prominently in the form of femme fatale
hollywood she longs to become a
live-action noid a process she
accomplishes by sleeping with our human
protagonist you might think jessica
rabbit was raunchy but she has nothing
on holly a character who wants to become
human in large part to experience what
human women feel when they do it with a
man if you're looking to share a
groundbreaking fusion of live action and
animation with your kids stick to the
denizens of toontown even with jessica
rabbit's sordid games of petty cake
you can't talk about superheroes without
talking about stan lee
enough said as marvel's main man he
oversaw the creation of household names
like spider-man black panther and the
hulk he reshaped the tone of the entire
genre and he lived to see the transition
of his characters from the page to the
screen dozens of times over and became a
pop culture icon in his own right of
course like any creator not everything
he made reached such heights of success
sure you've heard of the fantastic four
but you're probably less acquainted with
later work like hero man romeo and
juliet the war or the guardian project a
team of superheroes based on hockey
teams yet omnipresent or obscure a
stanley creation can generally be
depended upon to entertain fans of all
ages
right
well not when it comes to stripperella a
spike tv cartoon that debuted in 2003
the pamela anderson helmed series is
about as far from family friendly as it
gets it stars erotica jones yes really
an exotic dancer who moonlights as a
superhero only 13 episodes were made
before it got cancelled probably because
the world wasn't ready for a show that
combined stan lee fabio mark hamill and
pamela anderson
the years have seen adult swim throw all
sorts of animated weirdness at the wall
just to see what sticks there are
outright success stories with shows like
rick and morty the venture brothers and
other series that have made millions
changed the culture and inspired
imitators
and then there are the series like moral
oral a strange and sordid show that's
impossible to imagine airing anywhere
but within adult swim's sheltering
embrace a stop-motion series from the
mid-2000s moral oral is a parody of the
christian stop-motion series davey and
goliath and a devastating deconstruction
of mid-century americana oral our
wide-eyed hero is the sort of kid that
just wants to do right by god and grow
up to be like his dad but three seasons
worth of dysfunction reveal that nothing
in the seemingly pious town of morrilton
is as it seems his father drinks to
stifle his disillusionment with life his
mother cleans obsessively to avoid
having to parent his pastor has lost all
faith in god's love though this isn't at
heart a hopeless story oral is even
glimpsed as an adult having healed from
his family's abuse it's an unsparingly
bleak look at the cost of conformity but
how long does it actually take for love
to fade oh quicker than you think kid
quicker than you think
in this light the purpose of the show's
kid-friendly aesthetic becomes clear
every moment of darkness is also a
moment of exquisite tension between form
and content it's juxtaposition at its
most precise just make sure to keep the
box set on the highest shelf cleopatra
abraham lincoln and jfk walk into an
american high school but this isn't the
setup to a truly bizarre joke it's the
premise of the cult classic clone high
co-created for a single season run back
in 2002 by phil lord and christopher
miller the team better known today for
the lego movie and spider-man into the
spider-verse set in the fictional town
of exclamation clone high follows the
traumas triumphs and many very special
lessons a group of teens who happen to
be the clones of famous historical
figures endure as you might expect
they're part of a shadowy government
experiment but that matters a whole lot
less than anti-drug assemblies winter
proms and student
not
elections
your student body president can do for
you
ask what you can do to your student body
president's body
clone high's genius lies in its embrace
of contrast the clones of course
struggle mightily to live up to their
outsized reputations as aware as the
audience is of just how unimpressive
they are when set beside their ancestors
but the central tension comes to
fruition most deliciously in the show's
commitment to parodying teen soaps it's
funny to watch joan of arc reborn as a
sullen goth girl but it's priceless to
watch her learn not so serious very
special lessons about staying off drugs
and getting enough sleep add in a diner
called the grassy knoll and adolescent
john f kennedy who wants you to know
exactly how rock hard his abs are at all
times and a robotic reincarnation of mr
belvedere and you get a cartoon as
eccentric as it is hilarious
space ghost coast to coast is one of
those once in a generation shows that
combines nostalgia satire and sheer
baffling weirdness it's a talk show
starring one of hannah barbera's lesser
known heroes in which actual real life
celebrities are interviewed it's strange
but space ghost only grew more surreal
with time it's success acting as a sort
of springboard for some of the most
peculiar work adult swim has ever aired
even when compared to strange successors
like tom goes to the mayor that's how
groundbreaking stage setting and
perfectly odd space ghost was and
honestly we wouldn't mind if this iconic
cartoon got a reboot nobody cares moby
nobody cares
no one it's also one of the shows on
this list most easily mistaken by a kid
for something aimed at them space ghost
coast-to-coast doesn't pelt the viewer
with violence or intimate situations the
way other adult-oriented animated shows
do instead it dwells with surreal calm
in a valley of absurd early seasons see
space ghost not quite understanding of
who his guests are or how the world
works even assuming everyone is a
superhero and asking them about their
powers later seasons get even weirder as
we see him hawk a shampoo that makes you
smarter get afflicted by a curse that
drives him to cannibalism and becomes
saddled with terrible licensing deals
the show is a creative force of nature
responsible in large part for what would
go on to become an entire generation of
adult animation
little ones will likely just be creeped
out by its flights of dark fancy or
given an entirely incorrect idea of
space ghost's popularity as a
conventional superhero
generally speaking the west has always
seen cartoons as kids stuff adult
animation has certainly made gains the
simpsons isn't exactly obscure but even
then those gains have mostly been
limited to tv sitcoms not movies
thanks to disney dominance one could be
forgiven for thinking even the few
animated films directed at adults that
we've gotten are part of a very recent
trend that probably goes back no further
than a decade or two that assumption is
off by about 50 years thanks to 1972's
fritz the cat this isn't just an
animated movie that happens to be
intended for adults it was originally
x-rated the first animated film in the
united states to be so and for a whole
lot of very good reasons adapted from
the legendarily taboo work of cartoonist
r crum fritz the cat follows the feline
wannabe poet on a journey through the
free love era's deepest pits of hedonism
though director ralph bakshi has
correctly identified that fritz the cat
is a little less shocking by today's
standards it's still the kind of stuff
that you don't want to see a whole lot
of in mainstream movies animated or
otherwise
this is after all a movie in which a
cartoon cat engages in group intercourse
gets high hides from the cops and ends
up on a motorcycle with a neo-nazi
rabbit in isolation however the
characters often look like the soft
cuddly sort of mascots one might find on
school supplies in his big red sweater
fritz in particular is eye-catchingly
cute and just as wildly horrifically
inappropriate for the crowd most
cartoons about fuzzy animals are meant
for
eonflux contains multitudes gnostic
philosophy late 90s club wear and techno
utopianism are all a big part of the
slickly animated series it's a show with
a vision of the future that's as stylish
as it is horrifying the titular eon is
an assassin locked in eternal war
between the anarchic country of monaca
and the ruthlessly ordered nation of
bregna there's nowhere else to live upon
the blighted earth of the far future
making eon's mission as crucial as it is
pointless her world is one of extremes
emphasized by the show's
boundary-pushing aesthetics eon herself
is so ludicrously sexualized that she
goes entirely round the bend and ends up
grotesque
that purposefully off-putting style has
its roots and animation of a very
different sort the kind for kids far too
young for eon flux creator peter chung
got his start working on rugrats the
standard bearer of the lumpy 1990s
nickelodeon look indeed eon looks
startlingly natural when placed beside
tommy pickles and cartoons like the wild
thornberries that carried on its
aesthetic legacy
from an animation nerd point of view
this is a fascinating bit of connected
tissue between some very unlikely works
of art but for anyone in charge of
making sure kids don't get a spy
thriller laced with bondage imagery with
the playpen bound adventures of a band
of early 90s toddlers it's to be noted
with care
gendy tartakovsky's neon tale of a
time-displaced samurai was one of the
coolest things a kid in 2001 could watch
and yes it could be watched by kids
while robots bleeding oil and ravers
with pacifiers hinted at violent films
and drug-soaked parties respectively
samurai jack only ever alluded to these
inspirations borrowing their outlaw cool
without portraying the actual law
breaking at hand what resulted was a
landmark achievement so beloved that it
was given a chance to end its story
properly 13 years after it went off the
air thus was born samurai jack's fifth
season which aired in 2017. jack's
audience had grown up in the intervening
years and the show honored that by
making a conclusive season for the
adults they were instead of the children
they'd been this isn't to say samurai
jack changed its tone entirely it's
pretty easy to imagine a well-adjusted
12 year old who loves the first four
seasons being judged mature enough to
view it by his parents but still the
jack revival's tv 14 rating is earned
blood flows thickly assassins are
impaled upon spears and there are brief
implications of sexuality as it stands
now young fans of samurai jack can enjoy
the first four seasons to their hearts
content but an adult is probably going
to need to make the judgment call of
whether or not they're ready for the
final installment check out one of our
newest videos right here plus more
looper videos about your favorite shows
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]